And so I'm a little shook. I'm a little
shook. Like I
I didn't even set my stream up until
probably like 20 30 minutes ago.
Um
yeah. Uh so everybody sees the news.
Charlie Charlie was uh un alived. He was
shot. He died
leaving behind his wife and his uh two
kids.
It's tough, man.
I was just saying here on TikTok,
it's the same spirit but different skin.
That same spirit attacking the
uh LGBT
woke movement is that same spirit that's
in Islam that wants to un alive and
persecute the Christians and those who
criticize Muhammad.
You can't beat us. You can't refute us.
So, you got to try to kill us. That same
spirit
that was in the Pharisees that delivered
Jesus over to the Gentile Romans to have
him crucified. The same spirit
in those Jews who had Steven stoned and
unal alive. The same spirit and those
who had James unal alived. That same
spirit
that had Paul and the other apostles
unal alived.
It's that same spirit, just different
skin.
Different skin,
wants to get rid of the believers,
especially the ones that's making a
difference, the ones that are out there
in the front lines.
And I can understand if you're in a if
you're in a you know under Roman
occupation. I can understand you getting
martyed like that. I if you're you know
within
a Muslim country and you out there
preaching the gospel boldly and loud in
front of the Cabba or something. I got
you know you probably not going to make
it out of there.
But you at a co you at a college campus
in what is supposed to be known as the
free country that promotes so-called
free speech
and you you get martyed at a college.
Someone snipes you at a college. You're
not running for president. You're not uh
you have no political office.
What you have done is you have
transformed or helped transform and
start this movement of free discussion
and criticism,
facts over feelings
and you get martyed at a college campus.
That's different. That's how you know
you're doing something right.
One after the next, they come up, you
invite them over, you set a mic up for
them to step up. Any free person can
sign up and set up and set step up and
have the conversation, have the
discussion.
And that's what happens.
You get martyed at a college campus not
for inciting violence, not for you know
starting up a movement against the
government or something like that. You
are pre are are criticizing certain
social worldviews,
speaking truth,
waking up the masses,
encouraging and inspiring a bunch of
young people to also consider these
ideas and think critically and not allow
the popular social narrative to
guide the way you think and move and
live. But challenging these things, you
get martyed at a college campus.
So like I say to my ex-Muslim brothers
and sisters who have come to Christ and
you know are persecuted and called all
kind of things out of your name and you
know all that kind of stuff. Just the
same for those who used to support the
LGBT, you know, movement and the trans
movement and they came out of that and
now those same people that they used to
be friends with and support start reving
them and saying all kind of vow things
and you know harassing them. You guys
are in good company. Charlie Kirk,
you're in good company because Jesus
said it. He already told us.
He said, "They did it to me first, so
they're going to do it to you.
They hated me, so they're going to hate
you. They persecuted me and the
prophets, so they're going to do the
same to you." Here's the attitude that
we should have in this. Even though this
is sad, even though we're grieving, lose
a brother or a sister, it just anybody,
we just a human being being martyed like
like this. Yes. Exactly. this type of
hate crime.
We still rejoice in the Lord.
We still take refuge in the Lord.
We still delight in the Lord because we
know that we're on the right side.
They can unalive us. They can imprison
us,
put us in chains, but we've already won.
Christ already won the victory.
It's just a matter of time before he
comes,
cracks the sky, holding his heavyweight
division belt, championship belt,
showing the world. Told you
we rejoice in the Lord, guys. We grieve.
We grieve the loss of our brothers and
sisters.
We grieve it. Look, even a Muslim just
say, "You next logic."
I rejoice in this. We rejoice in this.
God has not given us the spirit of fear
but of love and a sound mind. We have
power and we boast in the Lord. And
because of this, when this stuff can
when this stuff happens, guess what? We
get louder.
We get bigger.
We get stronger.
This should ignite all of you guys who
are familiar with who Charlie Kirk is.
This should ignite something in you to
want to get up, get out, and spread the
gospel, spread the truth, and be
unapologetic about it.
All right, so those are my words, man.
God bless his family. Prayers to his
wife and his and his kids that he's
leaving behind. It's really sad. Um, but
let's show support to that family, guys.
Let's show support to that family. Let's
pray for them. Let's lift them up in
prayer and let's uh,
you know, let's carry on. Let's carry on
what Charlie Kirk was doing. Let's
continue. Pray for all of us that are on
the front lines. That could be any of
us, guys. That could be any of us.
It could be any of us.
right? Me, David Wood, IP, Vocab,
you know, all those all the type of guys
that are out there in the front lines
hitting the street. It can be any of us
and we know that.
Keep your keep us in your prayers. Keep
us in your prayers. Pray that God guards
us. He protects us. Keep us in your
prayers. But we all know that we are not
exempt from any type of persecution and
martyrdom. We're not exempt.
We just love the Lord and we love his
people and we love human beings and we
want them to be saved.
So despite the danger, despite the
threats that we get from Muslims and the
LGBT and the woke and the left, despite
all this, we love them enough to risk
our lives and honor the Lord in that way
and plant the seed.
So all right, let's get to some super
chats here. We got prayers for Kirk, for
the Kirk family. We need more love in
this hateful world. Exactly.
Sparkley says, "Stay safe. You too,
Avery. Sad people can do this." Yep.
La for Christ says, "Praying for you,
brother. Every time you go out to ev uh
to evangelize in the in the mighty name
of Jesus." Amen.
Juan says, "I love Charlie, bro. Just
wanted to put this out there, bro. Be
safe out there cuz you are out there.
Pray for you, bro. A lot of these people
are wicked. You in the front lines. Just
be safe out there. Love you, ma'am. Love
you too. Juan
Sham says, "Why I have always been
worried about you when you are out there
preaching the gospel. Be safe. Be
strong. God has Charlie now." That I
that I am sure of. That's right.
Um
let's see. Oh, this is beautiful. High
on mercury says to live is Christ
and to die is gain.
Charlie lived Christ so fully and with
his martyrdom has gained eternal life
with our Lord.
Patriotic Z says you never see
conservatives and Christians do this
stuff. Always the left and Muslims doing
this stuff. If you have to resort to
unaliving, then your position is weak.
Shows you can't intellectually defend
your point.
Yeah. Christopher says, Philippians 1
21, for to me,
for to me to live is Christ and to die
is gain. His master said to him, well
done, good and faithful servant. You
have been faithful over a little. I will
set you over
over much.
[Music]
Enter to in man
It's okay.
>> It's okay.
>> Love you, too, sweetheart.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Still got to do this.
>> That's all.
>> Yeah.
Sure enough,
you know, it's it's a it's weird because
it's uh
this is beautiful, you know.
Philippians 121, y'all. It could be any
of us.
It happened to Christ first.
It happened to the apostles. It happened
to the prophets.
It happens to believers.
It's happening to Christians right now
as we speak. This is just a small
example.
This is just a small example.
Christians are being martyed all over
the place in Nigeria and China.
All over the place, man.
Still dying for the love of the Lord.
Still putting themselves out there for
the love of the Lord, for the gospel,
for the truth.
And whether we
live throughout our years a full life,
you know, it's amazing because we're
still planting more seeds while we're
here. We're preaching. We're doing the
work. We're paving the way for our Lord
while we're here. If we die, then we're
with the Lord and other believers.
We don't lose.
We don't lose. We don't lose nothing.
To live is Christ and to die is gain. We
don't lose.
You don't lose.
We believers do not lose. We've already
won.
And we're just here working in the
harvest.
So
all glory to God, man. All glory to God.
All glory to God. He is faithful. He is
true. And he is victorious.
And because he is victorious, we are
victorious. We have the victory
over Satan and over his kingdom.
All glory to God. The true God
who vindicates his servants even in
their death, who will have his
vengeance.
It's not our job. He will have his
vengeance. And it's going to be a tough
day for those who were against him.
It's going to be a tough day for those
who rose up against God and his and his
saints,
his servants, his loved ones. It's going
to be a tough day.
That's why
that's why we pray. We That's why we're
doing this, guys. We want you guys who
are non-believers who watch us all the
time. We want you to be saved.
We don't want you to be on that side
with the goats. We want you to be on the
side with the sheep who's going to be
granted eternal life,
granted into the kingdom,
not thrown away into the fire,
begging, wishing that you had made a
different decision.
Hear our hear me right now. If you don't
hear anything, repent and be saved.
Repent and believe in the gospel. Turn
from whatever falsehood you're in and
believe in the gospel, bro.